this is the azot chemical plant in
sivera donetsk on ukraine's eastern
front line
hundreds of civilians including women
and children are reportedly sheltering
in its bunkers after suffering some of
the heaviest fighting and most intense
artillery bombardment since the war
began four months ago ukrainian forces
have begun retreating from the city
unfortunately our boys will have to be
withdrawn but there's no need to talk
about so-called betrayal as nobody's
going to abandon them no one will let
the russian forces surround them
nearly every building in several donetsk
is partially or completely destroyed
it's a similar situation in neighbouring
lissy chansk as the shelling gets
heavier the relocation of remaining
civilians who want to leave gets more
perilous by the day
there is reportedly no running water or
electricity but still some people refuse
the offer of safe passage to the
ukrainian side
i'm only with my mother now i do not
want to leave i think we need to endure
a bit more and everything will be okay
ukrainian army released footage believed
to have been shot at least a week ago
showing ukrainian soldiers laying mines
and then blowing up one of the four
bridges connecting several donetsk with
lissy chance to the south a tactical
move to slow down the russian advance
the russian ministry of defence released
video it says shows ukrainian soldiers
taken prisoner in the nearby town of
zolote these ukrainian military vehicles
are heading south from lycychansk but
russian forces are shelling the main
road out in an effort to cut off a major
supply and exit route for the ukrainian
army and civilian evacuees russian
forces are pushing into severe donetsk
and towards neighbouring lesians from
the north the east and the south they
also control large areas to the west
the regional governor says that
ukrainian forces are pulling back in
what he describes as a tactical
withdrawal
but the news suggests a potential defeat
for the ukrainian army in one of the
last two cities in lugansk region under
their control charles stratford
al-jazeera kiev